social distancing supposed to be more
than two meters apart you're supposed to
you're supposed to be more than three
meters apart move out the way
Dominic Cummings the Prime Minister's
top advisor today ever so keen on
enforcing the rules but questions
mounting over a 260 mile trip to Durham
at the height of the lockdown but its
fate now rests on whether it was legal
and reasonable but one thing is clear
it's a question of doing the right thing
what about what you guys think today
with a press conference about transport
millions of pounds spent lots of new
roads to be built it's almost as if they
wanted to distract no matter how great
we make the railways of the future
millions will still rely on the car like
Dominic Cummings who used his car to
travel halfway across England giving his
child welfare as the reason what do you
say today to all those people who are
unable to say goodbye to their loved
ones or go to their funerals because
they were observing the letter of the
rules everyone has done their best to
try to do the right things the as I read
out before I won't repeat the guidance
again but it does essentially interpret
it as taking practical steps to ensure
that you follow the measures as best as
possible I understand what you're saying
I get what you're saying
you know mr. Cummings is a you know in
the public eye but the reality of the
matter is of the four-year-old child's
welfare what seemed like precise rules
at the time now appear to have been open
to common sense interpretation the
public health advices take yourself out
of society if you like as soon as you
have symptoms stay at home stay at home
with your family all of the guidance has
a common-sense element to it which
includes safeguarding around adults all
children can you just clear up
actually what went on so mr. Cummings
went to a Durham property and he stayed
inside back with his wife and child all
in the same property and members of
their family delivered food to their
doorstep why did that necessitate that
journey 260 miles why couldn't he have
done that in London I guess the simple
answer is that's where the family was
that's where the sister was and
underneath so you know as we all do in
moments of crisis we always seek to have
our family those who can assist us
around us Boris Johnson gives Dominic
Cummings his full support and funnily
enough so did many of the cabinet on
Twitter the opposition say it's
double-standards
Labour's Rachel Reeves writing to
cabinet secretary mark Sidwell calling
for an investigation
she said the British people have made
important and painful sacrifices to
support the national effort including
being away from family in times of need
it is therefore vital that the
government can reassure the public that
its most senior figures have been
adhering to the same rules as everyone
else bricks it right you will Dominic
Cummings the master of understanding and
being on the right side of public
opinion but what will they all make of
this
Sam Coates Sky News